giving nine-year-olds yeah okay your boy
what's the nine-year-old boy into what's
he like he is funny he's really funny he
loves to act he loves tell him like he
loves like he's been in a couple of the
movies the TV shows I've been on but he
has these interesting like views or
things that are so fancy right we went
to Disneyland Disneyland has their like
the Star Wars thing where like the kids
could become a Jedi
yeah now I've learned this maybe right
before he signed up that he wanted to be
a part of the dark side right and we
stepped on a tub but he hates Jedi's he
think the Jedi is really evil and what
they did is terrible they don't dress
right wait he doesn't like the Jedi's
yeah I'm a twenty two Jedi's do that was
so terrible well if you ask him right
and he broke it down I can t really
repeat it cuz I was sitting there
listening light and it baby convinced me
you know I don't let you stop I can
either now you know because you know
that even though the darkside is
supposed to be Eve with the jedis of
Mesa really bad selfishness Luke tried
to kill Han Solo's son right that's what
he said that's how he said it
you know it's for a reason I mean I
don't even know that much about it but
they say you are mitigating
circumstances so what does he like so
much about the dark side they dress
better which is true they do dress
better the Jedi house which a nice dress
Jedi's are just usually wearing like oh
yeah I got this said so it's it looks
like they just stole the bathrobe you
write the darts that I had like the
black leather they got the boots they
got the cool cakes they got the red yeah
yeah they just look cooler you got the
gloves yeah JIT asking like scarves all
of you look like circle scarf though
everything's a scarf move there in
Aerosmith yeah
so what is what's your is your daughter
is she similar or she Brittany
Brittany's a lot different but like you
know and it's so funny you have
different lationship especially started
getting this age 10 and I like my
daughters like my best friend
I'd she'd only when it checks on me
everybody else always acts of the stuff
she just like Dani how was your day you
have a good meeting today is that a good
script right there you really you're
really kid that would have me thinking
what are you up to
Pharrell what's going on here what do
you know that I don't know I think she
would actually take like it's so crazy
like cuz little boys are different like
I'm not sure of my son's to take care of
me
I know she will I feel like if I lost
everything and I needed somewhere to
stay
she'll do it like she'll argue with her
husband make sure I'm staying you know
I'll be in the kitchen listening
pistachios why they already quit shaman
yeah I'm here mob think about that you
think about who's gonna take care of
you'll take care of yeah I just think
sons tend to be like and I'm not saying
like even with my dad we're not doing it
to him like we taking care of him but
you know it is we're like guys hey man
cuz this is think about I think you know
take care of my father I've learned two
things I learned some of the stuff my
momma complained about was right what do
you mean your dad's kind of a character
he's funny man he's like you know he'd
be just making up stuff like he like he
didn't pay his light bill I don't know
if how long it was like a crazy amount
of money and I called him say hey man
you win the last time you paid you paid
the bill two weeks ago you haven't
brought yeah you a bill about two years
I don't know what a lights still on
right
he did not talk to somebody but he fried
need to talk to somebody but it probably
wasn't a light company right
so this him comment call it pizza look I
pay my light bill and so and it's he is
he's kind of an angry guy or not really
no he's a either he's an interesting guy
he's not angry but he can get he's been
in this weird irritating space which is
why I'm not sure if I'm screening a
special in Chicago and I'm just not sure
if I'm gonna invite him cuz I don't know
if he's gonna like like if some of the
stories are exaggerating I wanna but any
truth is yelling out and praying the
theater were people in everybody yeah
that's what what happened I talk about
my family a lot are just my my engine
you know I love my family but I say
stuff every now and then I my mother was
always like I never did that you know
she's always like the woman in the Marx
Brothers movies
[Laughter]
well her big saying is he Andy you've
been around for this what my mom would
say I'd say something just as a joke and
she'd say I don't like that even fooling
my mom says that I don't like that even
fooling like I've been a comedian for 32
years
well I don't like you even fooling
entertain with that